The Russian Figure skating Team Will
Still Get bronze medals From the 2022
Beijing olympics despite The
disqualification of camilla beva in a
doping Case The International skating
Union has published an updated result
This morning The United States Is The
New Olympic Team Champion and Japan gets
upgraded to  Silver however The demoted
russians Get Third Place by A Single
Point ahead of fourth Place Canada even
When stripped of the Points Skater beva
earned On
We do not agree with these
decisions, not with the court decision, not with the
decision of the
Federation, we do not
accept them Well, what can I say bad  it’s
very sad that not everyone probably
had hopes Well, not only on her but on the whole team
But well, she’s still young So I think that
she will definitely perform And show
Well, the highest results Unfortunately, it’s
very politicized to politicize this sport,
it’s unfair I think to deprive
the athlete who has their
she earned these awards through hard work, this is firstly
unethical, perhaps there is some kind of campaign
against her, saying that everything is
now banned. That is, this is the work of her
whole life, all her life she has been striving all her
life, she tried Yes, she tried to show
herself, that is, she has a very good
result  she is very capable And now
everyone says no, we won’t allow you at all
We will simply erase you from life in
fact, she simply erased her That is, I
think that this is
Unfair